we grew up with only cheap doughnuts
because that nobody had gourmet
doughnuts back then I'd have to say that
I prefer the classic stuff like simple
is better smell wise I can tell you it
smells the most fake a doughnut could
possibly smell it also happens to look
like a little butthole it's nice and
yellow I mean obviously like everyone
you know who grew up and then 80s and
90s has eaten one of these things it
leaves a greasy film on the roof of my
mouth which makes me sad it seems like
it might be like formed by some sort of
like injection gun and it's like foam
inside it's weird I'm gonna give this to
a two stars
it looks like it came out of a package
and it smells like some sort of weird
oil I want to say that this is like palm
oil that's really bad and like killing
the rainforest so this doughnut feels
like soggy on the bottom and a little
bit wet I'm gonna take a really small
bite because I'm not hopeful cuz it
smells pretty bad it's super gross but
it has that one weird old-school flavor
where it's like fake lemon an artificial
nutmeg it's both kind of like endearing
and also really disgusting
kind of like diet coke you know one star
this donut is from Winchell's and it's
really beautiful look it's the most
beautiful donut I've seen in a long time
so what you look for when you're making
a used to donut which is this risen
glazed donut is that this line forms
because the dough has risen you know at
the proper time and developed in a way
that it's gonna cook evenly on both
sides but you can see the spice in here
I don't know if this is the most
expensive donut you bought but like damn
it's pretty good this is probably the
peak of cheap Donuts and it's a five
star donut kudos to this donut person
they really did a great job
so this is a Dunkin Donuts raised glazed
doughnut it smells almost like nothing
which is really weird okay so it smells
really it smells like it's got some fake
stuff in it like fake vanilla it's got a
good texture though in terms of like the
squish and stuff but there's a really
odd bitter flavor this donut probably
gets like a - probably the most hyped
donut in America I have to say I'm a
little disappointed by this donut
because it looks really flat and it
feels really tight like either it's
stale or that the person proofing the
dough did not do a great job the glaze
is super thick it almost feels like it's
made out of wax the inside of the dough
has like no character at all it's really
white also basically this is if you took
like Wonder Bread and fried it and then
put glaze on it it pains me to say it a
one-star
[Music]